لقد استغرق الامر بعض الوقت لي اقتنع
بالقيام بارسال الذخائر العنقوديه
لاوكرانيا كلمات بايدن في لقاء مع السي ان
الذي اعلن فيه قرار ادارته الجديد بعض
الوقت قصد بها بايدن الشهورا من المناقشات
لكنه شخصيا اخذ اكثر من ذلك بكثير حتى
يغير قناعاته اكثر من اربعين عاما نحن في
العام
1982 غزت اسرائيل لبنان فيما اطلقت عليه
اطلقت عليه تل ابيب السلام الجليل كانت
التقرير التقرير تتحدث عن ارسال الولايات
المتحده ذخائر عنقوديه لاسرائيل وعن
استخدامها هذه الذخائر ضد المدنيين جو
بايدن السيناتور في الكونجرس وقتها عارض
الامر ورد على التقرير قائلا تل ابيب
تنتهك التزامها باستخدام ذخائرنا الغرض
دفاعي فقط يجب قطع القدره على الوصول الى
هذا النوع من الاسلحه في المستقبل اللافت
ان بايدن ادع وقت الى عقد جلسات استماع في
الكونجرس حول هذه القصه
وبمطالبته بعيدا المستمره رفقه عدد من
النواب وقتها عقد فعل الرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي انذاك بيجا اجتماعا مع مجموعه
من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ بحسب تقرير النشر في
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عام 1982 بجن اخبر
الاعضاء بمن فيهم بايدن انه لا يعرف ما
اذا كانت اسرائيل قد استخدمت قنابل
عنقوديه لكنه سيطلب من وزير دفاعه ريال
شارون تقريرا بهذا الشان لكن شبكه بريت
بارت الاخباريه حاولت معرفه المزيد من
التفاصيل وتحدثت مع شخص مقرب من بيجن يدعى
موشيزاك بحسب جاك ضرب بايدن الطاوله بيده
لتوضيح وجهه نظره الخاصه بقصه الذخائر
العنقوديه يرد عليه هذا المكتب مصمم
للكتابه وليس
للحكمات لن تخيفني التهديدات هل تعتقد انه
نظرا لان واشنطن تقرضنا المال ستفرض علينا
ما نفعله كان هذا في الخفاء اما في العالم
وبعد عودته لاسرائيل اثنى بيجن على بايدن
قال هناك شاب القى خطابا حماسيا للغايه
يجب ان اقول انه قد مر وقت طويل منذ ان
سمعت مثل هذا الموهوب يتحدث
عن تقدير وتاييد للمحادثات التي اجريناها
في واشنطن مع الرئيس ومستشاريه لقد تحدث
الوفدان الامريكي والاسرائيلي بكل صراحه
وتفصيل يمكننا حقا ان نجمع على اعتبار
نتائج اللقاءات مثمره للغايه
فيما يخص الذخائر العنقوديه استمر على هذا
النحو بمرور السنوات وصلنا للعام 2006
ولكن هناك اطرف مشتركه من الثمانينيات
اسرائيل ولبنان في عام 2006 وخلال الحرب
الاسرائيليه الثانيه على لبنان وقبل وقت
قصير من تولي بايدن منصب نائب الرئيس
لاوباما كان الجدل ايضا حول استخدام
اسرائيل للدخائر العنقوديه القديمه التي
تصنعها الولايات المتحده في مناطق ماهوله
بالسكان وكان بايدن موقفه كما كان معارض
وانضمت له في الراي السيناتور وقتها
هيلاري
ماذا حدث اذا لضميرك يا بايدن فرحه المرشح
الرئاسي الديمقراطي الحالي روبر اف كاندي
جونيور الذي ينافس باي المقعد المؤهل
للترشح للانتخابات الامريكيه المقبله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات